[Music]
so we have to be you gotta be the
husband to love it right that's all you
got look at the character select the
character yeah lover wife husband or dog
okay I'll be I'll be lover oh my god I
just had sex with no one somebody in my
house having sex no one oh [ __ ] I hope
the dog doesn't catch me I got the keys
okay
what am i doing in this game oh where
are you you'll never find okay oh god my
god [ __ ] I find the keys last name I
have a banana it's okay no get all the
bananas [ __ ] the banana make me slow
[ __ ] you're wrong bedroom boy oh not my
daughter's bedroom
[Music]
hey hey officer stand your ground
officer yeah that's right you better
watch out you know not not a step not a
step closer you know that I [ __ ] your
wife [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
but it was your wife all right
good game Emma Pepsi who did you invite
in my house god damn it mate yeah you
never find me Oh cinnamon what was that
what was that trying to get you to step
with a banana in the middle floor but
you kept going around it there's gotta
be a fresh banana let's do that again
what are you said of a [ __ ] Marcia I
love you
why'd you do this I don't believe that
that's you might yeah when I found this
gave me so lackluster were two because
they're supposed to be like a cheater or
whatever where the [ __ ] are you what
much
now this I'm strafing I'm strafing you
get it this [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you missed getting hey walk over
it see if it does anything I'm immune to
bananas donut have a donut are you
cold-hearted don't know don't do it dude
you're not [ __ ] downstairs you
[ __ ] [ __ ] looking at the streets
I'm using why is there banana peel here
I'm walking around that banana peel was
not there before you're playing the TV
son of a [ __ ] what do you do something
mind [ __ ] me with you goddamn banana
peel [ __ ] where are you son of a [ __ ]
no but close it with keys it clothes are
upstairs we're upstairs yeah the door
follow me I'll show you I'll take you to
your clothes kind sir oh yes there's one
of me yes there are your pants
go get them what what what I repair
Southside why don't you come in and get
your pants just get your pants
I got my trusty remote control oh I got
a [ __ ] oh you got a remote control
you gonna block me with that remote
control now can someone else join if
anybody wants to play you can download
this game called catch a lover and you
can play a couple of rounds with this
for video I'm starting to question your
your audience a bit there's 800 people
watching a stream but they won't play
no one oh my god wolf [ __ ]
oof shut the [ __ ] up Elliott I'm skating
yes all right
no not hey more like who do this banana
why don't you come here what all right
help me fine Oh find a key I find a key
panicky yes nice all right happy find my
clothes daddy daddy
my pants I found my shirt that's right
yeah you sound
get the gun and shoot wait no it's my
[Laughter]
where's my [ __ ] pants
I hear you when you get beamed to you
smack across the room it's a beautiful
sound dude iPhone 4 stun guns if they
come here so you made this house in this
house is [ __ ] lost they gotta be like
a murderer was that guy's name home
whatever [ __ ] try to stun you oh all
right all right all right help me find
my goddamn pants dog bad dog bad dog bad
dog err evil dog go away biscuit you're
bigger than this sick you supposed to
appeal in the floor somehow you have
like a full water thing and you can peel
before how do I dog oh yeah wait dog
come here there's water here so the dog
can drink the water and then piss dog
come in here he's gotta wait drink that
water no don't hit me for [ __ ] sake my
ankles drink the water your stupid dog
err drink the water dog drink the drink
[Laughter]
then wife's in it you used to be a dog
bad bad
[Music]
and that kids is how I Met Your Mother